Can you that's a good question? It really is. And I've thought about it many times. I'd like to say I was pressing it. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 59 recorded on December 2nd, 2021. My name is Connor. And today with my co host, Bryce, we continue part two of our conversation with father and son Otto and Eric Niebler. If you haven't listened to episode one, I highly recommend listening to that one first. I mentioned that the Wall Street area was going through some fairly heavy trauma during the late 60s.
Can you that's a good question? It really is. And I've thought about it many times. I'd like to say I was pressing it. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 59 recorded on December 2nd, 2021. My name is Connor. And today with my co host, Bryce, we continue part two of our conversation with father and son Otto and Eric Niebler. If you haven't listened to episode one, I highly recommend listening to that one first. I mentioned that the Wall Street area was going through some fairly heavy trauma during the late 60s.|||这是一个好问题吗？确实是。而且我思考过很多次。我倒是希望当时自己能有先见之明。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 59 期，录制于 2021 年 12 月 2 日。我是康纳。今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们继续与父子档奥托（Otto）和埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）对话的第二部分。如果你还没听过第一部分，我强烈建议先去听那一期。我提到华尔街地区在 60 年代后期经历了一些相当严重的创伤。
I don't know if you're familiar with that part of history of Wall Street. Wall Street has a tradition of being notoriously old school and reluctant to change. But what was happening is that the stock market was growing exponentially. And between 1965 and 1968, the volume of transactions on the exchange itself went from $5 million to $12 million within three years, which always destroyed Wall Street. Basically, whatever transaction occurred, a stock was traded. They would manually transfer the stock into the owner's name. It was a very manual process. It was on paper. You get a certificate, in effect. That destroyed three or four different brokerage firms. They couldn't keep up with it, and the SEC shut them down. I think the most notorious was Hayden Stone Brokers. They literally shut down that brokerage firm. And then they introduced something called Central Certificate Service,
I don't know if you're familiar with that part of history of Wall Street. Wall Street has a tradition of being notoriously old school and reluctant to change. But what was happening is that the stock market was growing exponentially. And between 1965 and 1968, the volume of transactions on the exchange itself went from $5 million to $12 million within three years, which always destroyed Wall Street. Basically, whatever transaction occurred, a stock was traded. They would manually transfer the stock into the owner's name. It was a very manual process. It was on paper. You get a certificate, in effect. That destroyed three or four different brokerage firms. They couldn't keep up with it, and the SEC shut them down. I think the most notorious was Hayden Stone Brokers. They literally shut down that brokerage firm. And then they introduced something called Central Certificate Service,|||我不知道你是否熟悉华尔街的那段历史。华尔街有一个传统，那就是出了名的保守且不愿改变。但当时发生的情况是，股市呈指数级增长。在 1965 年到 1968 年之间，交易所本身的交易量在三年内从 500 万美元飙升至 1200 万美元，这简直把华尔街搞垮了。基本上，无论发生什么交易，只要有股票被买卖，他们就得手动将股票过户到所有者名下。这是一个非常手动的过程，全都在纸上操作。实际上，你会拿到一张证书。这摧毁了三四家不同的经纪公司。他们根本跟不上节奏，最后被美国证券交易委员会（SEC）勒令关门。我想最出名的就是海登斯通经纪公司（Hayden Stone Brokers）。他们真的把那家经纪公司给关了。然后他们引入了一个叫做“中央凭证服务”（Central Certificate Service）的东西，
where they basically had a banking service introduced, but instead of money, they would have certificates in accounts. And to do the trading, they would actually do accounting postings where they transfer one into the other without any paper transfer. And that saved Wall Street's bacon for the most part. But that all required computers. So they all had to get on board very quickly and get all their back office operation translated into an automated system, but not without a lot of collateral damage. They lost about six to 10 brokerage firms that couldn't handle it.
where they basically had a banking service introduced, but instead of money, they would have certificates in accounts. And to do the trading, they would actually do accounting postings where they transfer one into the other without any paper transfer. And that saved Wall Street's bacon for the most part. But that all required computers. So they all had to get on board very quickly and get all their back office operation translated into an automated system, but not without a lot of collateral damage. They lost about six to 10 brokerage firms that couldn't handle it.|||在那里他们基本上引入了一种银行服务，但存入账户的不是金钱，而是证书。为了进行交易，他们实际上会进行会计过账，在没有任何纸质转移的情况下将一方转移到另一方。这在很大程度上拯救了华尔街。但这一切都需要计算机。所以他们都必须迅速加入进来，将所有的后台运营转化为自动化系统，但这免不了带来大量的附带损害。他们大约失去了六到十家无法应付这一切的经纪公司。
And they could not find anybody or couldn't find the staffing, the technology at that time. And if you were anything close to a computer, they would gobble you up and give you anything you wanted in terms of salary. If you could spell the word computer, you're hired. That's basically what it was. They had headhunters all over the place trying to get technology staff from one brokerage firm to the other brokerage firm. There was piracy on Wall Street just to get the right people.
And they could not find anybody or couldn't find the staffing, the technology at that time. And if you were anything close to a computer, they would gobble you up and give you anything you wanted in terms of salary. If you could spell the word computer, you're hired. That's basically what it was. They had headhunters all over the place trying to get technology staff from one brokerage firm to the other brokerage firm. There was piracy on Wall Street just to get the right people.|||而且他们当时找不到任何人，找不到足够的人手或技术人员。如果你哪怕跟计算机沾点边，他们都会把你抢走，并在薪水上满足你的任何要求。只要你能拼出“computer”这个词，你就被录用了。基本上就是这么回事。到处都是猎头，试图把技术人员从一家经纪公司挖到另一家经纪公司。华尔街甚至为了抢到合适的人才而出现了“海盗行为”。
That's basically how traumatic it was piracy on Wall Street just to get the right people. But that's basically how traumatic it was during the late 60s. Wow. Yeah, it's super interesting to hear because at one point in my career, I wanted to be like a quant and wanted to work on Wall Street. So I've read a ton of books about the 90s until the early 2000s. But it's a it was it's you know it's completely different world like to hear the early days of having to actually physically transfer oh i own this stock and it's a certificate and that was a trading house i couldn't keep up with that and then they would go under like versus now i mean it's basically algorithms and you know the human in the loop is is very minimal it's like you know a trader staring at 12 screens just monitoring what
That's basically how traumatic it was piracy on Wall Street just to get the right people. But that's basically how traumatic it was during the late 60s. Wow. Yeah, it's super interesting to hear because at one point in my career, I wanted to be like a quant and wanted to work on Wall Street. So I've read a ton of books about the 90s until the early 2000s. But it's a it was it's you know it's completely different world like to hear the early days of having to actually physically transfer oh i own this stock and it's a certificate and that was a trading house i couldn't keep up with that and then they would go under like versus now i mean it's basically algorithms and you know the human in the loop is is very minimal it's like you know a trader staring at 12 screens just monitoring what|||华尔街为了抢人甚至出现了“海盗行为”，60 年代后期的情况大致就是这么具有创伤性。哇。是的，听到这些超级有趣，因为在我职业生涯的某个阶段，我曾想成为一名量化分析师，想在华尔街工作。所以我读过大量关于 90 年代到 2000 年代初期的书。但这是一个……你知道，这是一个完全不同的世界，听到早期必须实际去转移——哦，我拥有这只股票，它是一张证书，而交易行却跟不上这种节奏然后倒闭——相比现在，我的意思是，基本上都是算法，你知道，人在其中的干预非常少，就像一个交易员盯着 12 个屏幕，只是在监控
a bunch of algorithm you know proprietary algorithms they're executing it's hard to even imagine like that time where you know computers aren't even uh in that system like that wall street it's amazing once they learned what computers could do wall street really grabbed the bit that ran with it uh they basically uh uh were uh totally automated within three or four years and but they began to realize the other potential other than being more efficient they also said that they could do a lot more in terms of scientific investing with the computers, doing the analysis rather than having people. So the automation process went very quickly once they realized the upside potential of computers. But it's an industry.
a bunch of algorithm you know proprietary algorithms they're executing it's hard to even imagine like that time where you know computers aren't even uh in that system like that wall street it's amazing once they learned what computers could do wall street really grabbed the bit that ran with it uh they basically uh uh were uh totally automated within three or four years and but they began to realize the other potential other than being more efficient they also said that they could do a lot more in terms of scientific investing with the computers, doing the analysis rather than having people. So the automation process went very quickly once they realized the upside potential of computers. But it's an industry.|||一堆算法，你知道，他们正在执行的专有算法。甚至很难想象那样一个时期，你知道，计算机甚至不在那个系统中，就像华尔街那样。太惊人了，一旦他们了解了计算机能做什么，华尔街就真的紧紧抓住这个机会全力以赴了。他们基本上在三四年内就完全实现了自动化，但他们开始意识到除了提高效率之外的其它潜力。他们还表示，借助计算机，他们可以在科学投资方面做更多事情，进行分析而不是依靠人工。因此，一旦意识到计算机的上涨潜力，自动化进程就推进得非常快。但这是一个行业。
It's an interesting evolution on Wall Street because Wall Street prior to had a very heavy reluctance to automate anything. Another interesting story about Wall Street is automating the specialist. The specialist on the floor of the exchange is a very unique individual. He basically buys when everybody's selling and sells when everybody's buying. His primary purpose is to stabilize the market so it doesn't go crazy. That's a unique feature of the New York Stock Exchange. But working with them personally, they're the biggest crooks on Wall Street. They basically are responsible for maybe a half a dozen stocks, and they basically have to stabilize the stocks.
It's an interesting evolution on Wall Street because Wall Street prior to had a very heavy reluctance to automate anything. Another interesting story about Wall Street is automating the specialist. The specialist on the floor of the exchange is a very unique individual. He basically buys when everybody's selling and sells when everybody's buying. His primary purpose is to stabilize the market so it doesn't go crazy. That's a unique feature of the New York Stock Exchange. But working with them personally, they're the biggest crooks on Wall Street. They basically are responsible for maybe a half a dozen stocks, and they basically have to stabilize the stocks.|||这是华尔街一个有趣的演变，因为在此之前，华尔街非常不愿意将任何事情自动化。关于华尔街的另一个有趣的故事是关于“专家”（specialist）的自动化。交易所大厅里的专家是一个非常独特的人物。他基本上在所有人都在卖出时买入，在所有人都在买入时卖出。他的主要目的是稳定市场，使其不至于发疯。这是纽约证券交易所的一个独特功能。但亲自与他们合作过就会发现，他们是华尔街最大的骗子。他们基本上负责大概半打左右的股票，并且基本上必须稳定这些股票。
But they trade on inside information very easily because they know what is going up and what's going down before anybody knows about it. And they all have proxy accounts that they could use very easily. And the SEC is always on top of that. One of the projects I was assigned is automating the specialist book. The book is where you post your trade. If you're a broker, you would approach a specialist and say, when this stock hits this price, sell or buy this stock for me. And he keeps that in a book. And it's a manual book. But we wanted to help him. And I was a very naive manager at the time, and I went down to the specialist and said,
And they trade on inside information very easily because they know what is going up and what's going down before anybody knows about it. And they all have proxy accounts that they could use very easily. And the SEC is always on top of that. One of the projects I was assigned is automating the specialist book. The book is where you post your trade. If you're a broker, you would approach a specialist and say, when this stock hits this price, sell or buy this stock for me. And he keeps that in a book. And it's a manual book. But we wanted to help him. And I was a very naive manager at the time, and I went down to the specialist and said,|||而且他们非常容易利用内幕消息进行交易，因为在任何人知道之前，他们就知道什么在涨，什么在跌。他们都有可以轻松使用的代理账户。而美国证券交易委员会（SEC）一直盯着这些。我被指派的项目之一就是将专家的账本自动化。账本是你发布交易的地方。如果你是一名经纪人，你会走到专家面前说，当这只股票达到这个价格时，帮我卖出或买入这只股票。他把这个记录在账本里。这是一个手写的账本。但我们想帮他。我当时是一个非常天真的经理，我找到专家说：
we're going to do a great thing for you. We're going to automate your book. And the words I got back were not very pleasant. To the effect is, like hell you will. And they didn't want any part of it because they feel that having the footprints of what they do available to the SEC is comparable to suicide. They didn't want any part of automation whatsoever.
we're going to do a great thing for you. We're going to automate your book. And the words I got back were not very pleasant. To the effect is, like hell you will. And they didn't want any part of it because they feel that having the footprints of what they do available to the SEC is comparable to suicide. They didn't want any part of automation whatsoever.|||我们要为你做一件伟大的事。我们要把你的账本自动化。我得到的答复可不怎么友好。大意是：见鬼去吧，你们休想。他们一点也不想沾边，因为他们觉得把他们所作所为的痕迹暴露给 SEC 就无异于自杀。他们根本不想沾染任何自动化。
They did not want Big Brother looking over their shoulder at all. But that type of automation was strictly unwon by the floor of the exchange. So did you end up being successful or what happened? At some point it said, thou shalt automate that book. And that was one of my projects as well. We automated the specialist book. And it turned out to be a blessing because it freed up the specialist, made him a little bit more honest, but also freed him up and made him a little more efficient.
They did not want Big Brother looking over their shoulder at all. But that type of automation was strictly unwon by the floor of the exchange. So did you end up being successful or what happened? At some point it said, thou shalt automate that book. And that was one of my projects as well. We automated the specialist book. And it turned out to be a blessing because it freed up the specialist, made him a little bit more honest, but also freed him up and made him a little more efficient.|||他们一点也不希望“老大哥”在他们身后监视。但这种自动化遭到了交易所大厅的坚决抵制。所以你们最后成功了吗，或者后来发生了什么？在某个时刻，上面下令了：“你必须把那个账本自动化。”这也是我的项目之一。我们实现了专家账本的自动化。事实证明这是一件好事，因为它解放了专家，使他变得更诚实了一点，同时也解放了他，使他效率更高了一点。
So he was able to do more work and get more money out. So it worked out well for the specialist. It was not without a fight. it's interesting that to hear that the thing that really drove the automation was that that increase in volume that is that the volume reached a point where there was no other there was no other alternative no that was that was a condition of the economy at the time the automation didn't have much to do with it automation basically alleviated the the stress of the added volume. And it was a lifesaver for Wall Street. It really was. But it did not generate that traffic. It was other things that caused that traffic.
So he was able to do more work and get more money out. So it worked out well for the specialist. It was not without a fight. it's interesting that to hear that the thing that really drove the automation was that that increase in volume that is that the volume reached a point where there was no other there was no other alternative no that was that was a condition of the economy at the time the automation didn't have much to do with it automation basically alleviated the the stress of the added volume. And it was a lifesaver for Wall Street. It really was. But it did not generate that traffic. It was other things that caused that traffic.|||所以他能够做更多的工作并赚取更多的钱。所以这对专家来说结果很好。当然这经历了一番争斗。有趣的是，听到真正推动自动化的原因是交易量的激增，也就是说交易量达到了别无选择的境地——不，那是当时经济状况导致的，自动化与此关系不大，自动化基本上只是缓解了增加的交易量带来的压力。它是华尔街的救命稻草。确实如此。但它并没有产生那些流量。是其他事情导致了那些流量。
So not to switch topics, but a couple of times earlier, you said referring to tech and how far things have come. If I recall correctly, you said in 56, when you saw the computer, you sort of knew it was going to be a big deal in spite of your parents or your dad being like, come on, you should reconsider staring down people's throats and be a dentist. And I'm not sure what the equivalent is today. If it's, you know, seeing something that how, how do you know it's going to have the impact it does? So do you know what led you to think that computers were going to have, like, cause my guess is there was a bunch of folks that saw computers and we're like, okay, like, I'm sure this will be neat, but like now they're they're everywhere what made you think that it was going to be it was going to be this game-changing thing or do you know can you that's a good question it really is and i've thought about it many times i'd like to say i i was prescient about what's happening to computers but i wasn't it was a type of thing that I thoroughly enjoyed doing. I looked at it as a game, actually.
So not to switch topics, but a couple of times earlier, you said referring to tech and how far things have come. If I recall correctly, you said in 56, when you saw the computer, you sort of knew it was going to be a big deal in spite of your parents or your dad being like, come on, you should reconsider staring down people's throats and be a dentist. And I'm not sure what the equivalent is today. If it's, you know, seeing something that how, how do you know it's going to have the impact it does? So do you know what led you to think that computers were going to have, like, cause my guess is there was a bunch of folks that saw computers and we're like, okay, like, I'm sure this will be neat, but like now they're they're everywhere what made you think that it was going to be it was going to be this game-changing thing or do you know can you that's a good question it really is and i've thought about it many times i'd like to say i i was prescient about what's happening to computers but i wasn't it was a type of thing that I thoroughly enjoyed doing. I looked at it as a game, actually.|||为了不跑题，不过刚才有好几次，你谈到技术以及技术已经发展到了多么地步。如果我没记错的话，你说过在 56 年，当你看到计算机时，你基本上就知道这会是一件大事，尽管你的父母或你父亲觉得：“得了吧，你应该重新考虑去看看人们的喉咙，当个牙医。”我不确定今天与之相当的是什么。如果是，你知道，看到某种东西——你如何知道它会产生那样的影响力？所以你知道是什么让你觉得计算机会有——因为我猜当时有一群人看到计算机时会想：“好吧，我确信这会很整洁，”但现在它们无处不在——是什么让你认为它会成为这种改变游戏规则的东西？或者你知道吗？这是一个好问题。确实是，而且我想过很多次。我希望我说自己对计算机的未来有先见之明，但我并没有。这是我非常喜欢做的一类事情。实际上，我把它当成了一场游戏。
And I said, would people be willing to pay me money to do something that I enjoy so much? And I said, well, I don't know if they will, but I'd like to find out. And I think that's what drove me, not the vision of tomorrow and what role it plays. GE had a lot to do with bringing the computer age into being. I don't know if you remember the 66 World's Fair. They had a beautiful exhibit about technology tomorrow. And that basically brought home the message of what really could happen with technology. I had the vision a lot before that.
And I said, would people be willing to pay me money to do something that I enjoy so much? And I said, well, I don't know if they will, but I'd like to find out. And I think that's what drove me, not the vision of tomorrow and what role it plays. GE had a lot to do with bringing the computer age into being. I don't know if you remember the 66 World's Fair. They had a beautiful exhibit about technology tomorrow. And that basically brought home the message of what really could happen with technology. I had the vision a lot before that.|||然后我说，人们会愿意付钱让我做一件我如此享受的事情吗？我说，嗯，我不知道他们是否愿意，但我很想弄清楚。我想这就是驱动我的动力，而不是对明天的愿景以及它扮演什么角色。通用电气（GE）对开启计算机时代有很大的功劳。我不知道你是否还记得 66 年的世界博览会。他们有一个关于未来技术的精美展览。这基本上把技术究竟能带来什么传递得深入人心。在此之前很久我就有这种愿景了。
Not the vision. I had the urge to be part of it well before that. I think that type of mentality is what really brought people really into interest and looking at it as a career. There is a tremendous potential. And I think one of the big companies like GE and others started talking about what could possibly happen if you really applied your imagination to it. What could possibly happen with a computer? It really boggled your mind.
Not the vision. I had the urge to be part of it well before that. I think that type of mentality is what really brought people really into interest and looking at it as a career. There is a tremendous potential. And I think one of the big companies like GE and others started talking about what could possibly happen if you really applied your imagination to it. What could possibly happen with a computer? It really boggled your mind.|||不是愿景。在此之前很久，我就有一种渴望成为其中一部分的冲动。我认为这种心态才是真正让人们产生浓厚兴趣并将其视作一项职业的东西。这里面有着巨大的潜力。而且我认为像 GE 这样的大公司和其他公司开始谈论，如果你真正发挥想象力，可能会发生什么。计算机可能会带来什么？这真的让人大开眼界。
What were some of the things that they showed at the 66 World Fair? It wasn't just computers. It was just the different types of transportation, different types of automation of the home. It was different types of communication. I can't be more specific than that, but they gave us examples of what it would look like in Tomorrowland. I think they had an actual exhibit called Tomorrowland
What were some of the things that they showed at the 66 World Fair? It wasn't just computers. It was just the different types of transportation, different types of automation of the home. It was different types of communication. I can't be more specific than that, but they gave us examples of what it would look like in Tomorrowland. I think they had an actual exhibit called Tomorrowland|||66 年世博会上他们展示了哪些东西？不仅仅是计算机。还有各种不同的交通工具、各种类型的家庭自动化。还有不同类型的通信。我无法给出比这更具体的细节，但他们给我们展示了“明日世界”（Tomorrowland）会是什么样子的例子。我想他们当时有一个名为“明日世界”的实际展览，
and it showed you a whole bunch of things, mostly around the home, around the transportation, around industry. At that time, Dick Tracy's talking watch was considered leading-edge technology. I'm trying to look up when the last actual, because I don't think World fairs were a thing when I yeah so when was the last world
and it showed you a whole bunch of things, mostly around the home, around the transportation, around industry. At that time, Dick Tracy's talking watch was considered leading-edge technology. I'm trying to look up when the last actual, because I don't think World fairs were a thing when I yeah so when was the last world|||上面展示了一大堆东西，大多围绕家庭、交通和工业。在当时，迪克·特雷西（Dick Tracy）的对讲手表被认为是尖端技术。我正试图查一下上一次真正的——因为我不认为在我那个时候世博会还是一回事——是的，那么上一次世博会是什么时候？
world fair while you're looking that up we should ask Eric about his time as a freelancer because I think that's one of the more, one of the more interesting periods of Eric's career. And this ties in with our other guest, Dave Abrahams, does it not? Yeah, yes, it does. Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah, actually. Yeah. So right, right, right. So, so I was,
world fair while you're looking that up we should ask Eric about his time as a freelancer because I think that's one of the more, one of the more interesting periods of Eric's career. And this ties in with our other guest, Dave Abrahams, does it not? Yeah, yes, it does. Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah, actually. Yeah. So right, right, right. So, so I was,|||在你查这个的时候，我们应该问问埃里克关于他做自由职业者的那段经历，因为我认为那是埃里克职业生涯中比较有趣的一段时期。这与我们的另一位嘉宾戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）有关，对吧？是的，确实如此。哦，是的。是的。对，事实上。对。所以，对，对，对。所以，当时我……
I was working at Microsoft and I started getting involved in, in boost a little bit. And I think I went to some sort of a, maybe I hadn't been involved in Boost just yet, but I went to a conference and at a conference I met Dave Abrahams. And I remember sitting at a bar with Dave just chatting over a beer. And we just seemed to be two peas in a pod. And we've looked at software and the current challenges in the software industry the same way. And I'm like, man, this is a great guy. He's doing interesting things.
I was working at Microsoft and I started getting involved in, in boost a little bit. And I think I went to some sort of a, maybe I hadn't been involved in Boost just yet, but I went to a conference and at a conference I met Dave Abrahams. And I remember sitting at a bar with Dave just chatting over a beer. And we just seemed to be two peas in a pod. And we've looked at software and the current challenges in the software industry the same way. And I'm like, man, this is a great guy. He's doing interesting things.|||我在微软工作，并开始稍微参与到 Boost 中。我想我去参加了某种——也许我当时还没参与 Boost，但我去参加了一个会议，在会议上我遇到了戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯。我记得我和戴夫坐在一间酒吧里，一边喝着啤酒一边聊天。我们俩似乎一拍即合。我们对软件以及软件行业当前面临的挑战看法一致。当时我就想，天哪，这是个极好的家伙。他正在做一些有趣的事情。
And I went back to Microsoft. And I was thinking about it and you know at this time dave was dave was already uh independent and he had uh his um boost consulting a business uh it was called boost consulting then um it wasn't boost pro yet um and uh and i thought you know that'd be a great life you know and i i kind of have this dream of travel and, you know, it would be nice to be free in order to travel and work remotely. This was a long time ago and I was like, hey, you know, if you need another consultant, let me know. I'm not particularly attached to my job here at Microsoft, and I thought nothing of it, and, you know, several months later, I got an email back from
And I went back to Microsoft. And I was thinking about it and you know at this time dave was dave was already uh independent and he had uh his um boost consulting a business uh it was called boost consulting then it wasn't boost pro yet um and uh and i thought you know that'd be a great life you know and i i kind of have this dream of travel and, you know, it would be nice to be free in order to travel and work remotely. This was a long time ago and I was like, hey, you know, if you need another consultant, let me know. I'm not particularly attached to my job here at Microsoft, and I thought nothing of it, and, you know, several months later, I got an email back from|||然后我回到了微软。我一直在考虑这件事，你知道，那个时候戴夫已经……嗯，独立了，他有他的……嗯，Boost 咨询业务，当时叫 Boost Consulting，还不叫 Boost Pro，嗯……然后我想，你知道，那会是很棒的生活，你知道，我有点那种旅行的梦想，你知道，如果能自由地去旅行并远程工作该多好。那是很久以前的事了，我就说，嘿，你知道，如果你需要另一个顾问，告诉我一声。我对我在微软的工作并不是特别依恋，我当时没多想，然后，你知道，几个月后，我收到了来自……的回复邮件。
Dave. He's like, are you still interested in being a consultant? And I was like, hell yeah. Quit Microsoft like post haste and started working with Dave. And it was fantastic, you know, because I was a nobody, right? I couldn't have started a consulting business on my own. I didn't have clients. I didn't have any sort of reputation in the industry or anything at all. So I got to ride Dave's coattails a bit. And, you know, he sent me work. I worked away. People seemed happy with the work. I enjoyed it. A lot of it was either proprietary development for companies or open source development that was sponsored by various companies that wanted to
Dave. He's like, are you still interested in being a consultant? And I was like, hell yeah. Quit Microsoft like post haste and started working with Dave. And it was fantastic, you know, because I was a nobody, right? I couldn't have started a consulting business on my own. I didn't have clients. I didn't have any sort of reputation in the industry or anything at all. So I got to ride Dave's coattails a bit. And, you know, he sent me work. I worked away. People seemed happy with the work. I enjoyed it. A lot of it was either proprietary development for companies or open source development that was sponsored by various companies that wanted to|||戴夫。他说：“你还对当顾问感兴趣吗？”我说：“当然！”二话不说辞掉了微软的工作，开始和戴夫一起工作。这太棒了，你知道，因为我当时是个无名小卒，对吧？我不可能自己开一家咨询公司。我没有客户，在行业里没有任何名气或任何资本。所以我多少算搭上了戴夫的顺风车。而且，你知道，他给我派活。我埋头苦干。大家对这些工作似乎都很满意。我也很享受。其中大部分要么是为公司进行的专有开发，要么是由希望……的各种公司赞助的开源开发。
let various libraries built. A couple of the Boost libraries are ones that I built while I was consulting with Dave. And I got very active in the committee. I got very active in boost.org and on, on the, on the mailing lists and, you know, learned all sorts of stuff about library development from all sorts of smart people. It was, it was a great time. You know, I, I, I got a chance to learn a ton of stuff and, and, and rub elbows with a lot of really great people. And so that was a fine time for me. And then eventually I did make myself location independent, not right away. And so I worked, I did a lot of that work while I was kind of knocking about.
let various libraries built. A couple of the Boost libraries are ones that I built while I was consulting with Dave. And I got very active in the committee. I got very active in boost.org and on, on the, on the, on the mailing lists and, you know, learned all sorts of stuff about library development from all sorts of smart people. It was, it was a great time. You know, I, I, I got a chance to learn a ton of stuff and, and, and rub elbows with a lot of really great people. And so that was a fine time for me. And then eventually I did make myself location independent, not right away. And so I worked, I did a lot of that work while I was kind of knocking about.|||构建各种库。有几个 Boost 库是我在跟戴夫做咨询时构建的。我在委员会里变得非常活跃。我在 boost.org 以及邮件列表上变得非常活跃，你知道，从各种聪明人那里学到了关于库开发的各种知识。那是一段极好的时光。你知道，我得到了学习大量知识的机会，并与许多真正伟大的人物并肩交流。所以对我来说那是一段美好的时光。然后我最终确实让自己做到了不局限于某个地理位置，虽然不是立刻实现的。因此我有很多工作都是在到处游荡的时候完成的。
You know, I was either in Australia or in Thailand or in Vietnam or New Zealand or anywhere in the U.S. or Canada. Or, you know, I just kind of knocked around and would set up shop for three, four months and then, you know, move wherever struck my fancy and do it over again. And I did that for several years while consulting. That was great. Eventually, you know, Dave got sick of doing, you know, running a business and got a good offer, like an offer he couldn't refuse, so to speak, from Apple to work on Swift, on Swift and to be the person steering the development of the standard library for the Swift programming language. And so Dave decided to snatch that opportunity.
You're either in Australia or in Thailand or in Vietnam or New Zealand or anywhere in the U.S. or Canada. Or, you know, I just kind of knocked around and would set up shop for three, four months and then, you know, move wherever struck my fancy and do it over again. And I did that for several years while consulting. That was great. Eventually, you know, Dave got sick of doing, you know, running a business and got a good offer, like an offer he couldn't refund, so to speak, from Apple to work on Swift, on Swift and to be the person steering the development of the standard library for the Swift programming language. And so Dave decided to snatch that opportunity.|||要么在澳大利亚，要么在泰国，要么在越南、新西兰，或者美国或加拿大的任何地方。或者，你知道，我只是到处闲逛，在一个地方落脚三四个月，然后，你知道，看心情搬到任何吸引我的地方，再重复一遍。我在做咨询的几年里一直这样做。那感觉太棒了。最终，你知道，戴夫厌倦了经营企业，并收到了来自苹果公司的一份无法拒绝的好邀请，邀请他去从事 Swift 相关的工作，并担任 Swift 编程语言标准库开发的负责人。因此戴夫决定抓住这个机会。
I would have too, I suppose. And that kind of left me high and dry. I was like, well, I was subcontracting to this guy. And now he's gone and for me. I enjoyed that a lot. You know, a lot of the clients that Dave had had, I inherited. So that was great. That made it real easy for me. And at that point, I had a bunch of libraries in Boost. I'd written some articles.
I would have too, I suppose. And that kind of left me high and dry. I was like, well, I was subcontracting to this guy. And now he's gone and for me. I enjoyed that a lot. You know, a lot of the clients that Dave had had, I inherited. So that was great. That made it real easy for me. And at that point, I had a bunch of libraries in Boost. I'd written some articles.|||我想我也会的。这把我晾在了一边，陷入了困境。我想，好吧，我原本是转包这个家伙的活儿。现在他走了，对我来说……我非常享受那段经历。你知道，戴夫以前的很多客户，我都继承了。所以这太棒了。这让我的工作变得非常轻松。而且在那时，我在 Boost 里已经有一堆库了。我写过一些文章。
Some people knew, you know, oh, okay, this guy's got a bit of a reputation. He's a C++ programmer. You know, hire this guy. And that was all wonderful. It was terrific. I loved it. I had a really brief stint when I came back from my travels at a startup called Intentional Software, which is a a programming uh they it was started by charles simoni with um you know if if folks don't know charles simoni he is um one of this microsoft ultra ultra rich people he he wrote excel i think he wrote word um And so he started this company about, you know, he wanted to popularize what he was calling intentional programming, which is basically the idea of, like, you know, domain-specific languages. You know, building a little workbench on which you can develop domain-specific languages to target various specific applications.
Some people knew, you know, oh, okay, this guy's got a bit of a reputation. He's a C++ programmer. You know, hire this guy. And that was all wonderful. It was terrific. I loved it. I had a really brief stint when I came back from my travels at a startup called Intentional Software, which is a a programming uh they it was started by charles simoni with um you know if if folks don't know charles simoni he is um one of this microsoft ultra ultra rich people he he wrote excel i think he wrote word um And so he started this company about, you, he wanted to popularize what he was calling intentional programming, which is basically the idea of, like, you know, domain-specific languages. You know, building a little workbench on which you can develop domain-specific languages to target various specific applications.|||有些人知道，你知道，哦，好吧，这家伙有点名气。他是个 C++ 程序员。你知道，雇这个人吧。这一切都太美妙了。太棒了。我爱极了。结束旅行回来后，我在一家名为 Intentional Software 的初创公司有过一段非常短暂的工作经历，那是一家编程……嗯，它是由查尔斯·西蒙尼（Charles Simonyi）创立的，嗯，如果大家不知道查尔斯·西蒙尼是谁，他是微软的超级大富豪之一，他写了 Excel，我想他还写了 Word……所以他创办这家公司是为了推广他所谓的“意向编程”（intentional programming），这基本上就是类似于领域特定语言（domain-specific languages）的概念。你知道，构建一个小的工作台，你可以在上面开发针对各种特定应用的领域特定语言。
Which is kind of a cool idea. But, you know, when you have as much money as Charles Simonier does, then there is no real pressure to ever ship a product. And so they just kind of like spun their wheels endlessly rewriting the, the engine. And, you know, after, after I think five, I lasted five months there after that, I was like, okay, this, this is crazy. I actually, I actually wanted to deliver value. So, so I quit that. And, and, and then, then I went back to consulting and eventually got myself a family and decided I needed a steady job.
Which is kind of a cool idea. But, you, when you have as much money as Charles Simonier does, then there is no real pressure to ever ship a product. And so they just kind of like spun their wheels endlessly rewriting the, the engine. And, you know, after, after I think five, I lasted five months there after that, I was like, okay, this, this is crazy. I actually, I actually wanted to deliver value. So, so I quit that. And, and, and then, then I went back to consulting and eventually got myself a family and decided I needed a steady job.|||这算是一个挺酷的想法。但是，当你拥有像查尔斯·西蒙尼那样多的财富时，你就没有真正发布产品的压力了。所以他们只是没完没了地空转，重写引擎。你知道，在……我想呆了五个月之后，我在那儿坚持了五个月，然后我觉得，好吧，这太疯狂了。我实际上——我实际上是想创造价值的。所以，所以我辞职了。然后，然后我又回到了咨询行业，最后组建了家庭，并决定我需要一份稳定的工作。
So I went and worked at Facebook. And that's how I ended up there. That's my story. Yeah, I would love to consult again. That would be that was a great, great time. But, you know, working at a company like NVIDIA has its has its perks. You know, I get to do bigger things because there's there's there's more will. There's more long term vision. There's more funding and more resources. There's more smart people that i get to interact with um and so uh you know like the work that i'm doing right now for instance like trying to um trying to give c++ um an async programming model um that's work that i you know i would have to either not do that or do it pro bono in my spare time if I were still consulting. Nobody would be
So I went and worked at Facebook. And that's how I ended up there. That's my story. Yeah, I would love to consult again. That would be that was a great, great time. But, you, working at a company like NVIDIA has its has its perks. You know, I get to do bigger things because there's there's there's more will. There's more long term vision. There's more funding and more resources. There's more smart people that i get to interact with um and so uh you know like the work that i'm doing right now for instance like trying to um trying to give c++ um an async programming model um that's work that i you know i would have to either not do that or do it pro bono in my spare time if I were still consulting. Nobody would be|||所以我去 Facebook 工作了。这就是我到那儿的原因。这就是我的故事。是的，我很乐意再次从事咨询工作。那曾是一段非常、非常美好的时光。但是，你知道，在像英伟达这样的公司工作有它的好处。你知道，我可以做更大事情，因为这里有更多的意愿。有更多的长期愿景。有更多的资金和更多的资源。有更多聪明的人可以与之互动……所以，你知道，比如我现在正在做的工作，例如试图……试图给 C++ 提供一个异步编程模型……如果我还在做咨询的话，这项工作我要么得不做，要么就得在业余时间免费做。没有人会
paying me to do that. So I consider myself actually really lucky right now to be not a consultant and working at a company like NVIDIA. It's interesting. I entered the C++ world in about 2010 and 2011. And at that time, it seemed to me like there were a lot more people who were freelancers who were doing consulting. And over the course of the last 10 years, it seems like pretty much all of the people who were freelancers have been gobbled up by some company. And it seems like it's sort of like it's it's uh it's this lost era where we had a lot of you know that that 2000 to 2010 era of boost development and we had a lot of folks that were um you know working as freelancers as consultants and uh or at you know small
paying me to do that. So I consider myself actually really lucky right now to be not a consultant and working at a company like NVIDIA. It's interesting. I entered the C++ world in about 2010 and 2011. And at that time, it seems to me like there were a lot more people who were freelancers who were doing consulting. And over the course of the last 10 years, it seems like pretty much all of the people who were freelancers have been gobbled up by some company. And it seems like it's sort of like it's it's uh it's this lost era where we had a lot of you know that that 2000 to 2010 era of boost development and we had a lot of folks that were um you know working as freelancers as consultants and uh or at you know small|||付钱让我做这个。所以我现在觉得自己真的很幸运，能不当顾问而在英伟达这样的公司工作。这很有趣。我是大约在 2010 年和 2011 年进入 C++ 世界的。当时，在我看来，有更多的人是自由职业者，在做咨询。而在过去的十年里，似乎几乎所有的自由职业者都被某家公司吞并了。这似乎有点像——这是一个失落的时代，当时我们有很多人，你知道，2000 到 2010 年代那段 Boost 开发的时期，我们有很多家伙，你知道，作为自由职业者、顾问工作，或者在……小型
companies and and i'm sure that i'm sure that there are still plenty of freelancers out there, but it seems like it was in some ways a different time. Yeah, I'm not sure if that's my perception also, but I'm not sure if it's an accurate perception. I have no way of actually figuring out whether there are fewer consultants now than there were then. It could also be, you know, you know, this is like a station in life. You know, when, when you're in your twenties and you don't have any responsibilities, you know, the idea of becoming a freelance consultant is really appealing. It doesn't matter if your income stream dries up for a certain amount of time. But, you know, and then, and you can, it's all right if you have to pay for your
companies and and i'm sure that i'm sure that there are still plenty of freelancers out there, but it seems like it was in some ways a different time. Yeah, I'm not sure if that's my perception also, but I'm not sure if it's an accurate perception. I have no way of actually figuring out whether there are fewer consultants now than there were then. It could also be, you know, you know, this is like a station in life. You know, when, when you're in your twenties and you don't have any responsibilities, you know, the idea of becoming a freelance consultant is really appealing. It doesn't matter if your income stream dries up for a certain amount of time. But, you know, and then, and you can, it's all right if you have to pay for your|||公司工作，并且我确信——我确信外面仍然有大量的自由职业者，但它在某些方面似乎已经是一个不同的时代了。是的，我不确定这是否也是我的看法，但我不知道这是否是一个准确的看法。我无法真正弄清楚现在的顾问是否比以前少了。这也可能是，你知道，这就像是人生中的一个阶段。你知道，当你在二十多岁且没有任何责任时，你知道，成为一名自由咨询顾问的想法真的很有吸引力。即使你的收入来源在一段时间内断了也没关系。但是，你知道，然后，你可以——如果你必须支付你的……也没关系
own insurance, health insurance, if you're in the U.S. and you have to do such things, then that's fine. But, you know, as people get older, they end up getting more responsibilities, families, house sort of thing. And then the idea of having an uneven or uncertain income stream is far less appealing. You know, it's sort of, that makes me think of another question, which is, at what point did, you know, software engineering today, being a software engineer is, you know, considered like a really good job. It's a really high paying job. Was that, that couldn't have always been the case, you know, at what point did it go from being, you know, a pretty good white collar job to being one of the, one of the jobs that a lot of people aspire to because it's
own insurance, health insurance, if you're in the U.S. and you have to do such things, then that's fine. But, you know, as people get older, they end up getting more responsibilities, families, house sort of thing. And then the idea of having an uneven or uncertain income stream is far less appealing. You know, it's sort of, that makes me think of another question, which is, at what point did, you know, software engineering today, being a software engineer is, you know, considered like a really good job. It's a really high paying job. Was that, that couldn't have always been the case, you know, at what point did it go from being, you know, a pretty good white collar job to being one of the, one of the jobs that a lot of people aspire to because it's|||自己的保险，健康保险，如果你在美国并且必须做这些事情，那也没问题。但是，你知道，随着人们年龄的增长，他们最终会承担更多的责任，比如家庭、房子之类的事情。然后，拥有不稳定或不确定的收入来源的想法就变得远没有那么吸引人了。你知道，这有点……这让我想起了另一个问题，那就是，在什么时候，你知道，今天的软件工程——作为一名软件工程人员，你知道，被认为是一份非常好的工作。这是一份薪水很高的高薪工作。情况一直如此吗？你知道，在什么时候，它从一份相当不错的白领工作变成了一种让许多人梦寐以求的工作，因为它是如此地……
so highly valued and, you know, well compensated? I mean, that's a good question. I mean, it certainly wasn't the case when I graduated college. I remember my starting salary at Microsoft was about 40K, which, you know, is not that much, you know, and not that much, you know, and it wasn't even all that much at the time. I mean, it was okay at the time, but it wasn't like, wow. So I think what happened was the internet, I think.
so highly valued and, you know, well compensated? I mean, that's a good question. I mean, it certainly wasn't the case when I graduated college. I remember my starting salary at Microsoft was about 40K, which, you know, is not that much, you know, and not that much, you know, and it wasn't even all that much at the time. I mean, it okay at the time, but it wasn't like, wow. So I think what happened was the internet, I think.|||受到高度重视并且，你知道，报酬丰厚？我的意思是，这是一个好问题。我的意思是，在我大学毕业时肯定不是这样的。我记得我在微软的起薪大约是 4K 美元，你知道，这其实没多少，你知道，而且在当时也没那么多。我的意思是，当时还可以，但还没到让人惊叹的程度。所以我想发生这一切的原因是互联网。
I think the internet and like the first bubble and all of these people that suddenly made themselves super rich in the Bay Area from the first bubble. All of a sudden, tech stock became a hot commodity. People can make a lot of money off of it and and that seems to have driven a lot of the software economy and and yeah so now now programmers you know get are highly in demand and get compensated really generously I mean I definitely know it was like when I, I grew up in the nineties and the, you know, 2000 to 2010. And I certainly had no notion at the time of, of software engineer being, you know, a high paying job or, you know, like a good job. And even when I like got into the industry at first, I didn't realize that like, it was a really good, a good place to be. It was just like, it was something that I was really passionate about. Yeah. That's interesting.
I think the internet and like the first bubble and all of these people that suddenly made themselves super rich in the Bay Area from the first bubble. All of a sudden, tech stock became a hot commodity. People can make a lot of money off of it and and that seems to have driven a lot of the software economy and and yeah so now now programmers you know get are highly in demand and get compensated really generously I mean I definitely know it was like when I, I grew up in the nineties and the, you know, 2000 to 2010. And I certainly had no notion at the time of, of software engineer being, you know, a high paying job or, you know, like a good job. And even when I like got into the industry at first, I didn't realize that like, it was a really good, a good place to be. It was just like, it was something that I was really passionate about. Yeah. That's interesting.|||我认为是互联网，比如第一次泡沫，以及所有这些在湾区从第一次泡沫中突然变得超级富有的人。突然之间，科技股成了抢手货。人们可以从中赚大钱，这似乎推动了整个软件经济的发展，是的，所以现在——现在程序员，你知道，需求量很大，而且报酬非常丰厚。我的意思是，我绝对清楚，就像我——我在 90 年代长大，你知道，2000 到 2010 年代。我当时肯定没有“软件工程师是一份高薪工作，或者你知道，是一份好工作”的概念。甚至当我最初进入这个行业时，我也没有意识到这真的是一个好地方、一个好去处。这只是因为我真的对它充满热情。是的。这很有趣。
I, you know, we, we just, I guess we just take it for granted these days, but that's, it's not always been that way. Yeah. That's like, it's, it's, it's, it's interesting to have heard Otto earlier say that, you know, back in the day that your dad didn't want you to be a computer programmer. Because, of course, like it was that wasn't even it was not just that it was not a job that people thought was high paid. It was not even something that people thought was a job. You couldn't even take it to university as a subject. You had to take math. Regarding the amount of pay that the system programmers get, it can be tracked to the reliance that industry has on computers. In my days, the use of computers was not considered a critical element within a corporation operation. It became essential, but its growth was gradual.
I, you know, we, we just, I guess we just take it for granted these days, but that's, it's not always been that way. Yeah. That's like, it's, it's, it's, it's interesting to have heard Otto earlier say that, you know, back in the day that your dad didn't want you to be a computer programmer. Because, of course, like it was that wasn't even it was not just that it was not a job that people thought was high paid. It was not even something that people thought was a job. You couldn't even take it to university as a subject. You had to take math. Regarding the amount of pay that the system programmers get, it can be tracked to the reliance that industry has on computers. In my days, the use of computers was not considered a critical element within a corporation operation. It became essential, but its growth was gradual.|||我，你知道，我们——我想我们现在只是认为这是理所当然的，但情况并非一直如此。是的。这就好像——听到奥托刚才说，你知道，在过去，你父亲不想让你成为一名计算机程序员，这很有趣。因为，当然，这甚至不仅在于它不是一份人们认为高薪的工作。这甚至不是人们认为是一份工作的东西。你甚至不能把它作为一门学科读大学。你必须选修数学。关于系统程序员获得的薪酬数额，可以追溯到行业对计算机的依赖。在我的时代，计算机的使用不被认为是公司运营中的关键要素。它后来变得必不可少，但它的增长是循序渐进的。
And as the growth became more and more, and the dependence on computers became more and more, I think the salaries of the supporting personnel, technology, technical personnel grew as well. And it really grew as the dependence on computers grew. In today's world, people can't envision what would happen if there was no computers. In my time,
And as the growth became more and more, and the dependence on computers became more and more, I think the salaries of the supporting personnel, technology, technical personnel grew as well. And it really grew as the dependence on computers grew. In today's world, people can't envision what would_what happen if there was no computers. In my time,|||随着这种增长越来越多，对计算机的依赖也越来越多，我认为支持人员、技术人员的薪水也随之增长。随着对计算机依赖的增长，薪水确实也在增长。在当今世界，人们无法想象如果没有计算机会发生什么。在我的时代，
it was considered an overhead expense. It was not considered that essential. That's in the early days. But it grew as the dependence on it grew, and so did the salaries. I remember you telling me in the early days, companies would buy these enormous computers and have them in display rooms so that people could see them just to impress investors and clients and such.
it was considered an overhead expense. It was not considered that essential. That's in the early days. But it grew as the dependence on it grew, and so did the salaries. I remember you telling me in the early days, companies would buy these enormous computers and have them in display rooms so that people could see them just to impress investors and clients and such.|||它被认为是一项管理费用。它并没有被认为那么必不可少。那是早期的情况.但随着对它的依赖增加，它不断发展，薪水也是如此。我记得你告诉我，在早期，公司会买这些庞大的计算机并将它们放在展示室里，以便人们可以看到它们，以此来给投资者和客户留下深刻印象。
And they wouldn't even like be using them to do anything they just have like blinking lights and the the whirling tapes and everything like that and you know to that to that point uh one of my first accounts when i worked for univac with a japanese import export company called mitsui located on located on Fifth Avenue in Midtown Manhattan. And I was the account rep on it, the technician to help install the product. And they had a ground floor operation where their computer site, like so many others, were glass enclosed and raised platform, drop ceiling. It occupied half the floor, bottom floor. The other half was on the other side of the aisle, both was glass enclosed. It was all accountants with compactuses. And the first tour I got from this gentleman, who was my counterpart,
And they wouldn't even like be using them to do anything they just have like blinking lights and the the whirling tapes and everything like that and you know to that to that point uh one of my first accounts when i worked for univac with a japanese import export company called mitsui located on located on Fifth Avenue in Midtown Manhattan. And I was the account rep on it, the technician to help install the product. And they had a ground floor operation where their computer site, like so many others, were glass enclosed and raised platform, drop ceiling. It occupied half the floor, bottom floor. The other half was on the other side of the aisle, both was glass enclosed. It was all accountants with compactuses. And the first tour I got from this gentleman, who was my counterpart,|||他们甚至不会用它们来做任何事情，它们只是有闪烁的灯光和旋转的磁带之类的一切。你知道，说到这一点，嗯，我在优利系统（Univac）工作时的第一个客户之一是一家名为三井（Mitsui）的日本进出口公司，位于曼哈顿中城第五大道。我是那里的客户代表，也是负责协助安装该产品的技术人员。他们的底层运营场地中，计算机机房像许多其他地方一样，是玻璃封闭的、高架地板、吊顶。它占据了底层的一半。另一半在走廊的另一侧，两边都是玻璃封闭的。里面全都是带着紧凑型书柜的会计师。这位与我同级别的绅士带我进行第一次参观时，
we walked down this aisle. On the left was this beautiful computer installation we just installed. And on the right was this glass-enclosed accounting room with at least 50 to 75 accountants using their practices. And I asked him, I says, what exactly are these guys doing? He says, every piece of output that comes out of this side, he points to the computer, is checked by this side. I wish I had a camera to take a picture of that because it represents the entire spectrum of accounting today.
we walked down this aisle. On the left was this beautiful computer installation we just installed. And on the right was this glass-enclosed accounting room with at least 50 to 75 accountants using their practices. And I asked him, I says, what exactly are these guys doing? He says, every piece of output that comes out of this side, he points to the computer, is checked by this side. I wish I had a camera to take a picture of that because it represents the entire spectrum of accounting today.|||我们走过这条走廊。左边是我们刚刚安装的这个漂亮的计算机装置。右边是这个玻璃封闭的会计室，里面至少有 50 到 75 名会计师在使用他们的业务方法。我问他，我说，这些人到底在干什么？他说，从这一边（他指着计算机）出来的每一份输出，都由这一边进行检查。我真希望当时有个相机把那个场景拍下来，因为它代表了当今会计的整个全景。
That was the story. It was interesting. That's hilarious. We're going to have to find a link to some sort of article detailing. Oh, you're going to have a lot of research due for show notes. There's like at least 10 things that I counted that you're going to have to link to. You're going to have to go and find that news story about the XYZ stock from the 60s. Yeah, it definitely exists.
That was the story. It was interesting. That's hilarious. We're going to have to find a link to some sort of article detailing. Oh, you're going to have a lot of research due for show notes. There's like at least 10 things that I counted that you're going to have to link to. You're going to have to go and find that news story about the XYZ stock from the 60s. Yeah, it definitely exists.|||这就是那个故事。很有趣。太搞笑了。我们得找一篇详细报道的链接。哦，你得为节目笔记做很多调研。我数了数，至少有 10 件事你需要给出链接。你得去找出那篇关于 60 年代 XYZ 股票的新闻报道。是的，它绝对存在。
I would love to find that. Yeah. It's got to be on the Wayback Machine at some point. Not the Wayback Machine. The internet's not existing. I was just actually thinking that. I was like. You might have to go look at like Microfees or something.
I would love to find that. Yeah. It's got to be on the Wayback Machine at some point. Not the Wayback Machine. The internet's not existing. I was just actually thinking that. I was like. You might have to go look at like Microfees or something.|||我很想找到它。是的。它肯定在某个时候被收录在 Wayback Machine 上。不是 Wayback Machine。当时互联网还没存在呢。我刚才其实正在想那个。我想……你可能得去看看缩微胶片（Microfees）之类的东西。
Yeah. Just to warn you at microfees or something. Yeah. Just to warn you guys, there are other articles. There were many mistakes made on the ticker. Not by my computer, not by my program, but this is false transactions that came out that they took exception to. That caused a lot of excitement. So there was many of this type of situation, not as bad as mine, but there were many mistakes made on the ticker that were corrected almost
Yeah. Just to warn you at microfees or something. Yeah. Just to warn you guys, there are other articles. There were many mistakes made on the ticker. Not by my computer, not by my program, but this is false transactions that came out that they took exception to. That caused a lot of excitement. So there was many of this type of situation, not as bad as mine, but there were many mistakes made on the ticker that were corrected almost|||是的。只是提醒你们注意缩微胶片之类的东西。是的。只是提醒你们大家，还有其他文章。股票行情收报机上出现过很多错误。不是由我的计算机引起的，也不是由我的程序引起的，但这是出现的虚假交易，引起了他们的异议。这引起了很大的轰动。所以有很多这种情况，虽然没有我的那么糟糕，但在行情收报机上犯了很多错误，几乎立刻就被纠正了。
immediately on the ticker. So that I'm sure got some, some press as well. Would we be looking at like Washington, the, the journal, is that it? The Wall Street Journal, is that what it is? Wall Street Journal, if you go back and track it, you should find it there. They would be the ones who would blow it up the best.
immediately on the ticker. So that I'm sure got some, some press as well. Would we be looking at like Washington, the, the journal, is that it? The Wall Street Journal, is that what it is? Wall Street Journal, if you go back and track it, you should find it there. They would be the ones who would blow it up the best.|||在行情收报机上立即纠正了。所以我确信这也引发了一些媒体报道。我们会去看像《华盛顿……》或者那份报纸吗？是《华尔街日报》吗？《华尔街日报》，如果你回去追踪它，你应该能在那里找到它。他们会是把这件事报道得最轰动的人。
And when was that? That was, what year was that, you think? Okay, let's see. That was somewhere between 67 and 70. It's late 60s. I would think it was after we had the machine installed and running. So I would think it's 1969 would be my guess. But there was hell to pay on that one, I'll tell you.
And when was that? That was, what year was that, you think? Okay, let's see. That was somewhere between 67 and 70. It's late 60s. I would think it was after we had the machine installed and running. So I would think it's 1969 would be my guess. But there was hell to pay on that one, I'll tell you.|||那是什么时候？那是——你觉得那是哪一年？好吧，让我想想。那是 67 到 70 年之间的某个时候。那是 60 年代末。我想应该是在我们安装并运行机器之后。所以我的猜测是 1969 年。但那次惹出了天大的麻烦，我跟你说。
If I find the exact some some sort of do you think it was your name in the paper when the story came out or no no okay they basically said it was a computer error the word actually actually was actually used i don't know if they said bug it was could be a mistake of the code i mean whatever they say at that time i don't know actually entered the lexicon i believe that bug was coined uh world war ii or post world war ii yeah grace hopper the mark one right the um yeah the moth that got stuck in the electro mechanical relay is that a true story i've heard i've heard it's a true story and then some people say that that's a story that is made up um is it true is it not you can go to a museum and see the actual moth the first bug yeah you can yeah i think it's at
If I find the exact some some sort of do you think it was your name in the paper when the story came out or no no okay they basically said it was a computer error the word actually actually was actually used i don't know if they said bug it was could be a mistake of the code i mean whatever they say at that time i don't know actually entered the lexicon i believe that bug was coined uh world war ii or post world war ii yeah grace hopper the mark one right the um yeah the moth that got stuck in the electro mechanical relay is that a true story i've heard i've heard it's a true story and then some people say that that's a story that is made up um is it true is it not you can go to a museum and see the actual moth the first bug yeah you can yeah i think it's at|||如果我找到确切的……当报道出来时，你觉得报纸上有你的名字吗？没有，没有。好吧，他们基本上说这是一个计算机错误。实际上，那个词确实被用到了。我不知道他们是否用了“bug”这个词，它可能是代码中的一个错误，我的意思是，无论他们在当时怎么说，我不知道它是否真的进入了词汇表。我相信“bug”这个词是在二战或二战后创造的。是的，格蕾丝·霍珀（Grace Hopper）的标志一号（Mark I），对吧？嗯，是的，那只卡在机电继电器里的飞蛾。这是一个真实的故事吗？我听说过，我听说这是一个真实的故事，然后有些人说这是一个编造的故事。嗯，它是真的还是假的？你可以去博物馆看看真正的飞蛾，也就是第一个 bug。是的，你可以。是的，我想它在
the computer history museum and uh it's certainly certainly at the very least it's from that era that terms from that era i have a good i have a good last question to finish on. So you mentioned too, Otto, that it was not just Eric that ended up, or maybe Eric, you were mentioning that you had a sister. Someone mentioned another offspring that also ended up. My daughter and Eric's sister. Yeah. And do we want to, do we, I'm not sure if it's a dangerous question to ask who turned who turned out better.
the computer history museum and uh it's certainly certainly at the very least it's from that era that terms from that era i have a good i have a good last question to finish on. So you mentioned too, Otto, that it was not just Eric that ended up, or maybe Eric, you were mentioning that you had a sister. Someone mentioned another offspring that also ended up. My daughter and Eric's sister. Yeah. And do we want to, do we, I'm not sure if it's a dangerous question to ask who turned who turned out better.|||计算机历史博物馆里，嗯，它至少——至少它是那个时代的产物，那个术语来自那个时代。我有一个很好的、适合作为结束的好问题。奥托，你也提到过，不仅是埃里克最终——或者也许是埃里克，你提到过你有一个姐姐。有人提到了另一个后代，他也最终……我的女儿和埃里克的姐姐。是的。我们是否想——我们是否，我不确定问谁表现得更好是不是一个危险的问题。
You know, you bought the computer. You had two kids. One one father is a relative term. Better is a relative term. Expert politician answer from a clearly experienced parent. We do very different things in in computers um christine is is mostly um um she does a lot of administration and and troubleshooting that sort of thing okay so not on the not on the code writing side no she's never gotten into writing code i've encouraged her to but um but she she doesn't seem to be all that interested in it did she ever ever play around with the computer that you were doing? What was it called?
You know, you bought the computer. You had two kids. One one father is a relative term. Better is a relative term. Expert politician answer from a clearly experienced parent. We do very different things in in computers um christine is is mostly um um she does a lot of administration and troubleshooting that sort of thing okay so not on the not on the code writing side no she's never gotten into writing code i've encouraged her to but um but she she doesn't seem to be all that interested in it did she ever ever play around with the computer that you were doing? What was it called?|||你知道，你买了计算机。你有了两个孩子。一个——父亲是一个相对的概念。更好是一个相对的概念。来自一位显然经验丰富的父母的专家级政客式回答。我们在计算机方面做着非常不同的事情。嗯，克里斯蒂娜（Christine）主要是——嗯，她做了大量的行政和故障排除之类的事情。好的，所以不在代码编写方面？不，她从来没有涉足过编写代码。我鼓励过她，但是——但是她似乎对此并没有太大兴趣。她有没有玩过你当时在用的那台计算机？它叫什么来着？
That was the IBM XT. The IBM XT. Did she mess around with it as a kid? No, she messed around with playing games like Eric did. Pong was a big one for her. What was the other one? A couple of very basic
That was the IBM XT. The IBM XT. Did she mess around with it as a kid? No, she messed around with playing games like Eric did. Pong was a big one for her. What was the other one? A couple of very basic|||那是 IBM XT。IBM XT。她小时候胡乱摆弄过它吗？没有，她像埃里克一样瞎玩游戏。“乓”（Pong）对她来说是个大游戏。另一个是什么？几个非常基础的
games at that time. Interesting. I don't actually have recollection of my sister in front of the PC playing games. Not like you. Not like you. Interesting.
games at that time. Interesting. I don't actually have recollection of my sister in front of the PC playing games. Not like you. Not like you. Interesting.|||当时的那些游戏。有趣。我其实对我的姐姐坐在电脑前玩游戏的记忆不多。不像你。不像你。有趣。
Well, maybe in some five-year anniversary or something, we'll do... We're going to have to put together some sort of bingo board. We've just checked off the Father-Son podcast. We'll have to get the Brother-Sister podcast at some point. Someone, actually, here we go. Listener out there, if you're interested in making us a bingo board, we will be taking submissions. And at some point, we will choose a bingo board
Well, maybe in some five-year anniversary or something, we'll do... We're going to have to put together some sort of bingo board. We've just checked off the Father-Son podcast. We'll have to get the Brother-Sister podcast at some point. Someone, actually, here we go. Listener out there, if you're interested in making us a bingo board, we will be taking submissions. And at some point, we will choose a bingo board|||好吧，也许在某个五周年纪念日左右，我们会做……我们得弄一个类似于宾果游戏板的东西。我们刚刚完成了“父子”播客。我们在某个时候还得做“兄妹”播客。有人，事实上，来吧。听众朋友们，如果你有兴趣为我们制作一个宾果游戏板，我们将接受投稿。在某个时候，我们会选择一个宾果游戏板
and we'll make our way through them. But yeah, this has been an absolute blast for me. Oh yeah, definitely. I think a ton of our listeners are going to have or the listener will have a fantastic time. These kinds of stories are just
and we'll make our way through them. But yeah, this has been an absolute blast for me. Oh yeah, definitely. I think a ton of our listeners are going to have or the listener will have a fantastic time. These kinds of stories are just|||然后我们照着它一路玩下去。但是，是的，对我来说这绝对是一次极大的狂欢。哦，是的，绝对的。我想我们的许多听众都会——或者听众会度过一段美妙的时光。这些类型的故事简直就是
it makes my mind sort of bend. Every once in a while you listen to CBPcast, you hear Jason talk about his, you know, PDP eight or whatever assembly that, you know, but like, this is even going back. This is going back literally to before. I think the first year that people say like, what's the earliest language?
it makes my mind sort of bend. Every once in a while you listen to CBPcast, you hear Jason talk about his, you know, PDP eight or whatever assembly that, you0 know, but like, this is even going back. This is going back literally to before. I think the first year that people say like, what's the earliest language?|||让我的大脑有点震撼。偶尔你听 CBPcast，你听到杰森谈论他的，你知道，PDP 8 或任何汇编语言，你知道，但是——这甚至还要回溯。这简直回溯到了——在……之前。我认为人们说“最早的语言是什么”的那第一年？
Is it Fortran? And like, I think that language is credited with like, is it 1955 or 1957? So to go back all the way to the beginning of that is it's super, super interesting to hear sort of what it was like back then. Cause it's, it's so unfathomable. You know, my first computer was, you know, in elementary school and we were already doing graphs and Excel and like we were word processing and it was, it was already pretty,
Is it Fortran? And like, I think that language is credited with like, is it 1955 or 1957? So to go back all the way to the beginning of that is it's super, super interesting to hear sort of what it was like back then. Cause it's, it's so unfathomable. You know, my first computer was, you know, in elementary school and we were already doing graphs and Excel and like we were word processing and it was, it was already pretty,|||是 Fortran 吗？而且，我认为那种语言被认为是在——是 1955 年还是 1957 年？所以一直追溯到那个起点，听到当时的情况是怎样的，真的超级、超级有趣。因为这太不可思议了。你知道，我的第一台计算机是在——你知道，在小学的时候，我们已经在做图表和 Excel，就像我们在做文字处理一样，而且当时已经相当……
pretty good situation. There was definitely no punch cards. It'll be interesting to see. Yeah. I'm sure there's some folks out there that listen to that have similar sort of whether they're wall street stories or other stories back in the day, a million, a million dollars, X, Y, Z. Am I glad that I only write like backend code and a bug for me is just like some manifestation and some Python code or something like that. I definitely don't have newspaper articles being written. I was the person that like filed the bug on Libstd C++ for them to make the ABI breaking change to std list in C++ 11. The one where they made it for one release and then like very rapidly put out another point release to un-ABI break it.
pretty good situation. There was definitely no punch cards. It'll be interesting to see. Yeah. I'm sure there's some folks out there that listen to that have similar sort of whether they're wall street stories or other stories back in the day, a million, a million dollars, X, Y, Z. Am I glad that I only write like backend code and a bug for me is just like some manifestation and some Python code or something like that. I definitely don't have newspaper articles being written. I was the person that like filed the bug on Libstd C++ for them to make the ABI breaking change to std list in C++ 11. The one where they made it for one release and then like very rapidly put out another point release to un-ABI break it.|||相当不错的境况了。绝对没有穿孔卡片。看看会发生什么很有趣。是的。我确信外面有一些听众，他们有类似的经历，无论是华尔街的故事还是当年的其他故事，一百万，一百万美元，X，Y，Z。我庆幸自己只写后端代码，而且对我来说一个 bug 只是某种 Python 代码中的某种表现形式或类似的东西。绝对不会有报纸文章来报道我。我就是那种在 Libstd C++ 上提交 bug 的人，为了让他们在 C++ 11 中对 std list 进行破坏 ABI 的更改。就是那种在一个版本中做了更改，然后非常迅速地发布另一个点版本来撤销 ABI 破坏的版本。
That's like the closest I've come to doing real hard. In for me, yes. Well, this has been an absolute blast. This is really fun. So much fun. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
That's like the closest I've come to doing real hard. In for me, yes. Well, this has been an absolute blast. This is really fun. So much fun. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||那是我做过最硬核的事情了。对我来说是这样的，是的。好吧，这绝对是一次极大的狂欢。这真的很有趣。非常有趣。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。